dans son rapport le bape conclut que la
somme des risques liés au projet énergie
saguenay dépasse celle de ses avantages
le ministre de l'environnement a rappelé
que son gouvernement avait posé trois
conditions pour aller de l'avant que le
projet soit socialement acceptable qu'il
favorise la transition énergétique et
qu'il contribue à la réduction mondiale
des gaz à effet de serre trois cibles
ratées selon benoît charette qui évite
le promoteur à refaire ses devoirs
la balle est dans le camp du promoteur
et c'était lui de soi renouveler son
argumentaire soin d'amener de nouveaux
éléments de réponse
sexuellement sur la base des trois
conditions que nous avons à plusieurs
reprises réitéré le projet ne se
qualifie pas à l'heure où on se parle
la mairesse de saguenay favorable au
projet se montre prudente pour la suite
des choses qu'on verra pour la suite si
le gouvernement décide d'autoriser de
délivrer un certificat d'autorisation
sera là pour accompagner naturellement
le promoteur il ya quand même pas mal de
travail à faire pour pouvoir répondre à
toutes les réserves durera pas chez gnl
québec on juge les conclusions du bape
lucide son président par intérim adnec
l'entreprise devra en faire plus pour
convaincre des bienfaits de son projet
notamment sur la diminution des gaz à
effet de serre sont que nos explications
n'est pas été suffisantes donc c'est
pour ça que on va continuer à travailler
justement pour pouvoir répondre à ces
questions que la commission a soulevé
pour les détracteurs de gnl québec le
rapport et si dévastateur qui devrait
signer le glas du projet le rapport du
bape dit que ce qui risque d'arriver
c'est une augmentation de 45 millions de
gaz de tonnes de gaz à effet de serre et
ça c'est l'équivalent de 60% des cas
patents du québec maintenant qu'on a eue
ce rapport du bape très clair il faut se
rassembler dans une vision d'avenir
l'émission d'avenir et les clairement
dans les technologies vertes dans la
transition énergétique transition juste
le ministre benoît charette attend les
conclusions de l'évaluation
environnementale prévu cet été avant de
suggérer au conseil des ministres de le
rejeter ou de l'accepter ici jean
françois coulombe radio-canada sac d